aujourd'hui je suis capable de supporter
toutes les situations même les plus
bizarres même les plus malaisantes genre
tu regardes la télé avec tes parents et
il y a une scène de sexe ou tu regardes
la télé et il y a une scène de sexe avec
tes parents
vraiment je peux tous supporter et j'ai
fini par aimer ça en fait le malaise
parce que c'est tellement pratique quand
tu vas être tranquille
imaginons dans le train je trouve qu'il
y a trop de bruit dans le compartiment
grâce au malaise en une seule phrase tu
peux débarrasser de tout le bruit autour
juste tu prends ton téléphone tu passes
m'en démarrer une conversation et puis
tu dis une seule phrase un tout petit
peu plus fort
contentement ou pas j'avais 11 ans papa
tu es tranquille mais jusqu'au terminus
ce sont en Belgique
la patrimoine
il y en a c'est le caramel beurre salé
autre votre avantage du malaise c'est
que c'est ludique avec mon mec on a
lancé un petit jeu qui consiste à dire
le truc le plus choquant le plus
malaisant possible en public et à chaque
fois surenchérir sur ce qu'on se répond
l'un l'autre
on a perdu quelques proches depuis qu'on
a commencé à faire ça mais d'un côté on
se dit qu'est-ce qu'une famille unique
comparer une bonne vanne
pour moi les vannes meurent pas et donc
et donc en fait ce jeu il y a quelques
mois il est collé à lui nous invite pour
aller dîner et je sais plus de quoi on
parle pendant le repas mais à un moment
mon mec dit un truc au sujet de ma
famille là je me retourne vers lui je
dis mais Seb
tu sais que toute ma famille est morte
énormément
personne ne sait quoi dire tout le monde
me regarde
je me dis c'est bon j'ai gagné
jamais il osé surenchérir là-dessus
alors que sans ses collègues de travail
c'est la première fois que je l'ai
rencontré j'ai gagné
et là il me regarde droit dans les yeux
et tout doucement
en même temps si tu avais pas grillé ce
stock
[Musique]
c'est là que j'ai compris que je
l'aimais
et je pense cette passion pour la
malaise elle me vient un peu de ma mère
qui j'ai pas eu de tes fleurs ou quoi
mais je pense qu'elle a créé le concept
de malaise
du jour elle a partagé sur Facebook je
cite Catherine 48 ans
plus on vieillit plus on aime les choses
qu'on détestait quand on était petit par
exemple les siestes et les fessées